punto en común es un experimento social
que reúne a seres humanos con creencias
opuestas estas discusiones pueden
contener puntos de vista que son el
resultado de la desinformación recuerden
investigar y ser críticos con sus
propios prejuicios mientras forman una
opinión por favor vean la humanidad de
los participantes fomentemos la empatía
este vídeo contiene discusiones sobre
temas delicados que pueden molestar a
algunos espectadores estás equiparando
inconvenientes menores en tu vida
privilegiada o
privilegiada yo no asumo eso de ti
porque yo soy privilegiada y eso está
bien pero por qué piensas eso eres un
hombre
[Música]
punto en común
adolescentes conservadores padres
liberal paso adelante si están de
acuerdo el gobierno no tiene derecho a
decirle a la gente qué hacer con su
cuerpo
vacunas sí
ya no creo que el gobierno tenga derecho
a elegir te lo siento bien vine por las
vacunas pero sé que muchos de ustedes
piensan y el aborto la cosa es que
cuando se trata de aborto hay dos
cuerpos involucrados la mujer y el feto
el feto tiene un latido tiene adn
debería tener derecho a la vida comience
a leer o no es cuando el corazón late el
latido comienza a las 4 semanas no solo
un grupo de células es vida a las 21
semanas puede vivir fuera del útero el
aborto es asesinato y muerte más del 90%
de los abortos se producen en las
primeras 10 semanas creo que eso no es
aceptable todavía tienen el potencial de
tener la vida la tasa de mortalidad de
un feto que es abortado es del 100%
moriría si es aborto tienes suerte de
nunca tener que experimentar lo que es
tomar esa decisión qué pasa si me
convierto en padre y la mujer a la que
embarazo quiero abortar
es una afectará entonces tendrías una
discusión con tu pareja de salud y es lo
que harán y tele pero una opción de
debatir con por desgracia en la
naturaleza humana si les quitas la
opción o el derecho
encontrarán otra forma y será inseguro y
apoyaría
apoyarías a la madre en ese escenario si
la madre tiene uno no si ella da a luz
la apoyaría diría que lo que no nos va a
apoyarla económicamente por el resto de
su vida por el resto de la vida del bebé
estás hablando de que quieres decir con
que él apoye como ciudadano si tiene un
bebé existe la manutención y proviene de
los impuestos hay orfanatos adopción
madres en espera esos sistemas están muy
rotos y muchos están tratando de detener
la financiación de programas así ahora
quiero preguntarles apoyan los mandatos
de vacunas si es que acabas de
argumentar que el gobierno no debe
decirte qué hacer con tu cuerpo porque
lo apoyas creo que el gobierno no
debería decirme qué hacer con mi cuerpo
pero tengo que aceptar las consecuencias
de las decisiones que tomo con mí las
vacunas por ejemplo creo que todos
deberían vacunarse porque porque es una
pandemia pero si no quieres hacerlo no
creo que el gobierno deba obligarte pero
tienes que sufrir las consecuencias de
tus acciones significa que no puedes ir
a ciertos lugares no puedes poner en
peligro a otros sé que dices que lo
hacen para protegernos pero el
coronavirus tiene una tasa de
supervivencia de casi 98 99 por ciento
pero obligan a vacunarse porque no con
la gripe estás equiparando
inconvenientes menores en tu vida
privilegiada
las sumas que mi vida es privilegiada yo
no asumo eso de ti porque yo soy
privilegiada y eso está bien pero porque
piensas eso eres un hombre la mayoría de
los suicidios son de hombres también los
que trabajan en lugares peligrosos y los
que van a la guerra y quién estableció
ese sistema sí quien esté en desacuerdo
dé un paso adelante creo que doy una
perspectiva única porque estoy de
acuerdo con la vacuna
creo que kobe fue un desastre y qué
pudo haber terminado antes si las cosas
fueran más organizadas de acuerdo en
cuanto a si el gobierno debería
intervenir en los cuerpos de las
personas creo que hay casos en los que
el gobierno debería proteger a la
sociedad en general en especial en casos
como una pandemia en la cual la
enfermedad podría arrasar ciudades y
como el consumo de drogas creo que el
gobierno debería intervenir porque
cuando tienes una sociedad adicta a los
opioides o al crack se extiende como un
fuego salvaje y lo he visto y es difícil
de controlar sin la ayuda del gobierno
en cuanto al tema del aborto es muy
complejo y en general siempre quiero
favorecer el derecho de la mujer a
elegir pero creo que también hay algo
fundamental que ambos plantearon en qué
momento un feto es un ser humano digamos
que un niño tiene ocho meses en el útero
y en ese momento el bebé tiene un
corazón un cerebro tiene piernas y
brazos creen que está bien que se le
ponga fin
nadie hace y nadie aborda un feto viable
a menos que sea una emergencia médica
que mataría al bebé y a la madre
me llamo ben soy un consultor de
negocios para una empresa de
telecomunicaciones y soy un padre
liberal cuando se trata del aborto no
estoy seguro de cuál es mi posición no
estoy a favor ni en contra mi nombre
están soy directora de ventas de una
empresa de diálisis y terapeuta y soy
una madre liberal en cuanto a mi opinión
sobre el aborto para ser sincera me
entristece mucho no puedo creer que
estemos retrocediendo al quitar el
derecho a elegir sobre su cuerpo no ser
un aliado el gp más hace que alguien sea
una mala persona
si es fuerte es un poco forma general de
decirlo yo cuestionaría la empatía eso y
su conciencia sobre las personas que les
rodean porque te garantizo que conoces a
alguien que es lg digo si discutir la
validez de la existencia de otros seres
humanos no es una cuestión política así
te guste o no algo malo te pasa si dicen
las personas trans no existen si existen
me gustaría pensar que es un mundo
seguro para hacer el eje l teco pero eso
sería ingenuo los matan sólo por ser
trans o
gay me da miedo tengo tres hijos tengo
tres varones uno de ellos es trans me
preocupa que por muy progresista que
parezca una nueva generación tengo
tengo que pensar sufrirá violencia todos
los padres se preocupan por eso es parte
del trabajo
amo y yo tengo un elemento más
mi hijo está en una de acuerdo relación
muy privilegiada donde tiene mucho apoyo
y eso ayuda pero a medida que su
implicación ídolo se amplía y mi esfera
de influencia se vuelve menos eficaz a
medida que envejece
hola soy cindy soy ama de casa y soy una
madre liberal uno de mis hijos es trans
desde hace dos años mi respuesta y la de
mi esposo fue genial quieres usar estos
pronombres y quieres elegir un nombre
consultamos con un especialista en
género para saber qué opciones hay y
vamos paso a paso
avanzaremos con la mejor información
posible y pasen adelante por favor
puedo proporcionar una perspectiva única
porque soy bisexual y creo que a no ser
un aliado siempre y cuando no estés
dañando a acosando o publicando en las
redes sociales cosas homofóbicas no creo
que seas una mala persona como cristiana
no creo que ser el jefe que concuerde
con la visión de dios de la familia no
significa que les falte el respeto pero
creo que es un pecado en lo que respecta
a tu fe qué pasaría si tu hijo te dijera
que es gay bisexual y trans creo que si
no se practica el pecado no es un
problema se puede tratar en especial con
la transición
suelen ser problemas mentales como la
depresión la ansiedad y esas cosas crees
que se puede enseñar a no ser gay no
reservas que apoyas a la terapia de
conversión no no creo que podamos
convertir a nadie para que haga algo yo
no condenaría a mi hijo al ostracismo
pero no lo apoyaría no apoyo ningún
pecado
creo que si quieres ser transgénero
puede serlo vivimos en una nación libre
pero si me pides mi opinión creo que los
hombres y las mujeres son diferentes
tenemos diferentes cromosomas estructura
ósea si eres una mujer transgénero te
sigo viendo como un hombre puedes
expresarte como una mujer pero no creo
que la sociedad deba decir que eres una
mujer digamos por ejemplo un hombre
biológico de 18 años que dice que es una
mujer todavía tiene genitales masculinos
podría entrar en un baño de mujeres y
mostrar sus genitales no estoy de
acuerdo con eso no creo que esté bien
eso no pasa si de verdad pasa eso es
transfobia veo que podría suceder sé que
no es común y no solo un trans podría
ser un hombre que se haciendo sarkozy
hombres si un hombre hetero representa
más peligro en un baño de mujeres que
una persona trans él lo sé pero eso está
la excusa es lo que trato de decir
apoyas los baños de género neutro las
mujeres los hombres pueden compartir el
baño no crees que eso podría aumentar
las posibilidades de violación jacques
existen es interesante que los hombres
sólo se preocupen por violaciones en el
baño cuando se tiene una conversación
sobre las personas trans pero el baño de
género neutro surgió de esta idea no la
idea de que las violaciones aumentaran
de repente debido a los baños de género
neutro viene de la transfobia
james hoy tengo 16 años y soy una
adolescente conservadora am creo que la
transición hace más daño que bien
nacemos en el cuerpo que se nos da y
debemos permanecer así dios nos creó a
su imagen y semejanza y no creo que
debamos cambiar nuestra forma de ser
poseer un arma es un derecho humano
básico
odio escuchar sobre los tiroteos en las
escuelas y noticias y sobre los tiroteos
en general es horrible saben spider-man
no va a venir a salvar a la gente así
que la gente tiene el derecho de
protegerse muchos tiradores tienen como
objetivo las zonas libres de armas
porque saben que no habrá una persona
que luche contra ellos hay tiroteos
masivos en las escuelas y eso es porque
son zonas libres de armas consideró que
tener un arma es un derecho miren a los
países que prohibieron las armas la
unión soviética la alemania nazi china
despojaron a sus ciudadanos de las armas
para poder oprimir los y creo que la
razón para la que nuestros padres
consagran la segunda enmienda es porque
querían que nos protegiera moss contra
el gobierno tiránico y contra el peligro
que nos rodea creo que desde la
perspectiva de las mujeres si una mujer
se mete en una situación peligrosa con
un hombre tener un arma y saber cómo
utilizarla es la única manera de
protegerme tener gas pimienta no me
ayudará siempre creo que se quitan las
armas los malos siempre tendrán las
hojas de una manera u otra yo vivo en
los ángeles y allí hay estrictas leyes
de control de armas yo creo que los
ángeles se convirtió en una ciudad
peligrosa y me siento muy inseguro
caminando por la calle sin un arma el
crimen está en aumento y creo que una de
las maneras de detenerlo es con un arma
creo que debe haber este control para
quien compra armas no puedes ir a una
tienda y comprar un arma debería haber
regulaciones sobre quién compra armas y
quién dispara
ajax o de bat y si iba a sentarme o no
porque creo que la gente tiene derecho a
tener armas mi problema es qué tipo de
armas tienen creo que la gente debería
ir a cazar pero se necesita un rifle
semiautomático en lo personal me dan
miedo las armas pero creo que debe haber
regulaciones más estrictas
la mayoría de las personas que mueren
por disparos son mujeres en una
situación de violencia doméstica en los
tiroteos masivos no hay rifles
automáticos nadie los necesita pero el
arma más peligrosa es la que está en tu
cajero preguntarte crees que las mujeres
deberían tener derecho a tener armas
para protegerse si no estoy en contra
del derecho a poseer armas la pregunta
era crees que poseer un arma es un
derecho humano y no estoy de acuerdo con
eso desde mi punto de vista crecí en un
barrio plagado de armas yo soy
propietario de una por el hecho de que
tuve que crear algún tipo de autodefensa
porque no estás de acuerdo no estoy de
acuerdo porque preferiría no tener la
creo que no es un derecho humano sino
que hace una necesidad para mucha gente
hay muchos barrios que son muy seguros
pero incluso en un barrio seguro te
pueden robar y matar me han asaltado
varias veces con una pistola y todo lo
que podía pensar era y si muero será
porque no tenía un arma para protegerme
crees que debemos eliminar las armas de
todo el mundo si si existiera como un
imán como magneto de x-men atraerá todas
las armas creo que sería un lugar mejor
mi opinión política afecta mis
relaciones con familiares y amigos
e
yo en el año 2020 cuando eeuu se puso
muy intenso políticamente mi profesora
era muy activa y quería que habláramos y
se dieron cuenta de que yo era
conservador y dijeron estás yendo en
contra de lo que creemos toda la escuela
es muy liberal y entonces me apartaron
sentiste que te acosaban y solo me
miraban algunas personas se acercaban y
decían que era racista o xenófobo me
preguntaban apoyas a trump pero yo los
miraba y les decía respeto tus opiniones
por favor respeta las mujeres que
tengamos las mismas ideas o no creo que
tiene una cualidad admirable a pesar de
recibir miradas o sentir que no
perteneces tienes tus convicciones puedo
respetar que tengas convicciones
creo que al ser liberales pensamos en la
derecha como si estuviera atascada en la
arena es interesante escuchar que los
liberales no tienen una opinión correcta
todos deberían tener su opinión creo que
estamos hablando de temas que no son una
cuestión de opinión sino de moral el
valor de las vidas humanas yo he tenido
que bloquear personas en facebook
miembros de la familia march o los
hombres que están casados con las
mujeres en mi familia era como esta
conversación se está volviendo personal
e hiriente y si sigues así te bloquear e
estaban acusando a sí y me sentí muy
acosada y menospreciada te condenaron al
ostracismo hubo alguien que creo que por
mi parte entiendo que la gente tiene
diferentes creencias y lo respeto y creo
que es bueno todos las compartan esa es
la forma en que progresamos pero creo
que cuando la gente se vuelve ignorante
u ofensiva sin ningún tipo de evidencia
o respaldo ese es el punto en el que
digo no debería ser amigo tuyo porque
puede sonreír en mi cara pero a mis
espaldas tienes un sentimiento diferente
no he perdido ninguna relación porque
mis amigos y yo no nos metemos en
política ellos y yo solo jugamos a
videojuegos y hablamos de cómics yo creo
que si pierdes una relación por la
política es triste por desgracia es
parte del crecimiento sí por supuesto
con suerte no perderás ningún amigo pero
a medida que te haces mayor empiezas a
pérez a telecinco mayores que nosotros
era así hace 20 años la política ha
cambiado mucho y creo que se está
asociando la política con la ética
realmente yo no me permitiría perder
ninguna amistad o relación creo que la
mayoría de nosotros el 80% estamos en el
medio con diferentes grados y están las
personas que son muy muy conservadoras
muy ultra liberales son valores atípicos
pero es sutil tienes a alguien con quien
te reúnes hablan pasan un buen rato pero
pero si saca el tema piensas o eres uno
de esos no te lo dicen a la cara es algo
sutil y también creo que con de las
redes sociales las opiniones de la gente
están más analista nunca entendí por qué
alguien publica opiniones políticas en
las redes sociales creo que es molesto
tengo tres hijos ellos saben más de
política que yo cuando estaba en edad de
votar es molesto sí y creo que es muy
alentador porque estarán más informados
que yo cuando tenía su edad solo hace
que la vida sea más divisiva hay
discusiones y se pierden relaciones
porque la política es una parte
importante de la vida
hola me llamo scott soy un un padre
liberal tengo muchos hijos tengo cuatro
mi hija mayor es de izquierda mis dos
hijas del medio están más o menos en el
medio y chase es conservador mi nombre
es 6 tengo 19 años y soy una adolescente
conservador con mi padre scott siempre
hablamos de política sobre todo de las
armas del gobierno y también de la
economía no estamos de acuerdo pero nos
gusta escuchar nuestras opiniones el
movimiento feminista está sobrevalorado
o así
la razón por la que me senté es porque
el feminismo tal y como lo conocemos en
los medios y en las marchas está
dirigido
por mujeres blancas y no hay mucha
intersección alidad por margaret
thatcher y sus hombres usan bía antony
una racista las mujeres que encabezaron
el movimiento sufragista no eran
inclusivas es verdad no querían derechos
para las mujeres blancas y ese discurso
nos ha seguido para ser excluyentes con
las mujeres negras discapacitadas de
color indígenas no creo que el feminismo
en eeuu se base en el racismo la razón
por la que hay más feministas blancas es
porque hay una mayor población blanca
hay más feministas blancas por eso
creo que en el inicio del feminismo las
feministas querían votos para las
mujeres que se les permitiera trabajar
que se les permitiera ir a las
universidades estoy de acuerdo con eso
pero creo que fueron muy lejos al decir
mi cuerpo mi elección y en decir que las
mujeres no son iguales que están
reprimidas por los hombres blancos y
todo eso
y no tenemos un largo camino por
recorrer no se ha hecho lo suficiente en
eeuu o en el mundo en eeuu sin duda el
mundo en general es peor que eeuu y
estoy de acuerdo creo que las mujeres
deberían poder hacer lo que hacen los
hombres pero también tenemos que
protegernos si quieres ser madre en casa
y dedicarte a ser uno de los trabajos
más difíciles deberías poder hacerlo
pero también deberías hablar con tu
pareja y poner las cosas en su sitio
para que estés protegida algunas mujeres
no lo hacen como un seguro de vida parte
del feminismo es poder cuidarnos el
capitalismo está fallando a nuestra
sociedad
este sistema sólo valora la producción
el consumismo producción consumismo
hasta que te mueres no funciona para
nadie más que para un porcentaje pequeño
de multimillonarios todo es una tontería
el sistema está amañado para que los
trabajadores sigan trabajando y los
ricos sean más ricos creo que hay algo
bueno en el capitalismo que es la parte
de la innovación pero en general el
capitalismo no es para los pobres hay
muchas industrias que no deberían tener
ningún tipo de capitalismo involucrado
en la medicina por ejemplo es injusto
que ciertas personas reciban mejor
atención que otras sólo porque tienen
más recursos quiénes son ellos para
determinar el valor de la vida el
sistema sanitario genera beneficios y
ese beneficio se crea a partir de la
miseria de otros de la enfermedad el
sistema penitenciario donde tiene es
cárceles que son propiedad privada y
allí lo que tienes es un hotel y quieres
llenar el hotel porque habría un negocio
que se beneficia del crimen
eso no tiene sentido si pones el
beneficio por delante de la gente la
gente siempre sufrirá
dijiste que solo los multimillonarios
tienen éxito en el capitalismo y no
estoy de acuerdo con eso porque soy el
ceo de mi empresa hace un par de meses
empecé una empresa de joyería y no soy
multimillonario pero es relativamente
exitosa puedo pagar el alquiler y pagar
la universidad creo que hay gente como
yo que tiene una empresa a la que el
capitalismo beneficia si el capitalismo
no es la solución entonces cuáles no lo
sabes socialismo socialismo
hablan de cómo el capitalismo perjudica
a la clase media pero con el socialismo
democrático la clase media va a pagar
más impuestos no sólo los ricos los
ricos no pagan impuestos porque no
trabajan ganan dinero con los activos la
clase media trabaja y porque trabaja la
gran más impuestos bajo una propuesta
como la de bernie sanders o cortes o el
genoma yo estoy de acuerdo con pagar
impuestos me encantaría que la gente que
gana miles de millones pagará su parte
justa de impuestos pero aumentarlos para
mejorar la situación de la en general es
lo que defiendo no estoy seguro de que
el socialismo sea la respuesta verdadera
en yugoslavia antes de la segunda guerra
mundial les fue bien pero pero no
también y se eliminó lo que pienso es
que el capitalismo aunque no es la mejor
solución es una de las mejores
soluciones para una gran sociedad
democrática en el socialismo pensamos en
la distribución de la riqueza y el
dinero se convierte en un papel
importante porque los que tienen menos
dinero se vuelven envidiosos de los que
tienen más dinero y el dinero se
convierte en un dios porque no quieres
que nadie más lo tenga y si por ejemplo
miramos a los países escandinavos tienen
un mercado capitalista pero una
distribución de la riqueza socialista y
por eso funciona y yo que vengo de
europa lo he visto
crees que de su función no sucedió que
eso funcione creo que quita mucho dinero
a los ricos y a la clase media
mi nombre es night and tengo 18 años me
gustaría preguntar si creen que eeuu es
el mejor país del mundo si no están de
acuerdo con eso quiero saber qué país
creen que es mejor que eeuu creo que es
una bendición y un privilegio vivir en
un país que te da la libertad de
expresar lo que quieres ser el sueño
americano ha muerto
sí
tengo que
y tengo que decir que no estoy de
acuerdo con la frase sueño americano
para quien para los nativos americanos
que masacramos para las personas
esclavizadas esta idea romántica de que
existe este sueño es publicidad para el
capitalismo es una propaganda muy bien
financiada ha inspirado buenos actos y
buenas personas para hacer cosas buenas
por supuesto porque en última instancia
en un sentido amplio la humanidad es
buena pero esta idea del sueño americano
creo que la fantasía del mismo se está
desgarrando y creo que eso es
emocionante porque abre espacio para que
crezca algo mejor algo más inclusivo
annan creo que la frase es un poco cursi
pero me identifico con la idea de que
alguien se está construyendo en el
capitalismo porque yo lo estoy haciendo
y con mi negocio así que no creo que
esté muerto creo que el sueño americano
está muriendo no es el mismo que hace 30
años tener una familia comprar una casa
tener un gran trabajo ahora es muy
difícil comprar los ingresos no
aumentaron en comparación con los
precios de una casa creo que están
muriendo pero no creo que esté muerto
por completo porque hay muchos
inmigrantes que siguen intentando venir
eeuu tiene la mayor población de
inmigrantes el 14% de nuestra población
son inmigrantes tenemos mucha gente en
nuestra frontera sur todos quieren venir
a estados en que el sueño americano
todavía existe y soy testigo de eso
porque mi familia vino de un país del
tercer mundo
pero también existe la pesadilla
americana la gente que sufre no sólo
aquí sino también en todo el mundo
debido a las políticas a la explotación
a la colonización a muchos elementos que
estaban al alcance de eeuu eeuu tiene
mucha sangre en sus manos y mucha gente
no quiere dejar su país de origen pero
las situaciones que crearon allí están
obligando a la gente a irse a mi madre
le hubiera encantado quedarse en mexico
pero debido a la pobreza que tuvo que
ver con el tratado de libre comercio de
américa del norte y lo que ocurrió en
1994 causado por eeuu y que crearon esta
migración hay mejores oportunidades aquí
si nosotros vinimos y enviamos dinero a
nuestros ancestros cuando nos gustaría
quedarnos si eso sería una mejor opción
como inmigrante creo que el sueño
americano todavía existe anhelamos las
oportunidades que la gente tiene aquí el
trabajo las innovaciones que están
disponibles en esta economía del libre
mercado de este país capitalista el
sueño americano está en el ojo del que
mira si eres un inmigrante o si vives
aquí es diferente será diferente no me
gusta la idea del sueño americano pero
soy una persona que siempre va a creer
en la esperanza si trabajas duro y
aprovechas las oportunidades puedes
marcar la diferencia en tu vida tú eres
un ejemplo de ello estoy muy sorprendida
con ustedes creo que es increíble lo que
están haciendo aún tan temprana estoy
impresionada mi esperanza es que sigan
con la mente abierta y que estén
dispuestos a aprender y no solo escuchar
eso sí muy bien genial
[Risas]
gracias por venir gratis hielo a
graduación serás un buen abogado algún
día gracias fue genial papá